from your own life and your own
experiences with filmmaking what's
something that you learned the hard way
that you now correct or you now see
through right away red flags whatever
but it took you a little bit I think
that one of the most difficult things
I've ever learned as a filmmaker and
this comes back to something we were
talking about earlier is that when you
first start out there's all these people
you tend to work with and you work with
them on repeat not because you are
necessarily working with the best people
but because they're the people they're
accessible to you and what happens is
over time you start working with the
same people over and over and over again
some of them are good some of them are
bad but eventually there comes a point
where different talents and different
skill sets are not helpful to broader
goals and what you have to do is you
have to start letting some people go and
replacing them with people that are
better and that will make you better and
that is I think one of the hardest most
difficult things for you to swallow
because it's not just professional it's
also personal and I think on every
project you work on you pick up one
person that you say that person needs to
come back to my next film that person
needs to come back to my next film but
if you get to the point where you start
recycling every single person on every
single project your work instantly
becomes stale because there are no new
ideas being injected into it so as a
filmmaker you've got to constantly be
finding ways to reinventing yourself and
one of the first ways you do that is by
finding fresh new faces and fresh new
ideas
you